hello everyone it is an honor to join
you in commemorating the Life and Legacy
of Ed Ziggler
Ed was a mentor teacher and friend
his work has been inspirational to me
and many others in our field
and his profound influence extends well
beyond psychology for me he set an
example of how science and policy can
join hands to benefit the lives of many
and mobilize science in the service of
the public interest
[Music]
was a poor child that's when I became so
interested
in the Head Start program I actually had
my own Head Start program my uh my
parents said were immigrants
anyway for not my first language
but back in those days and to this day
there's a phenomenon in this country
that we call settlement houses like the
Henry settlement house in New York City
and these settlement houses were
actually terrific they helped
enculturate these families into the
country Ed talked about his childhood in
Kansas City and he talked about being
the child of immigrants and being poor
and growing up really in a rough and
tumble world and how that prepared him
for his work and really inspired him to
do the work that he did later in life
and and he also talked about what a good
Street Fighter he was and how that was
necessary in the world in which he grew
up in we went to Woodland it was a
demonstration school it was hooked to
the Kansas City Teachers College
reading uh interest in the community
community services all of those kinds of
things were part of our curriculum and
were very natural to us that invited me
to have a beer with one of his sisters
Maureen Argonne who was an interior
decorator living in the Kansas City area
they called him Eddie it was a reminder
that Ed was a human being in addition to
being a Titan of early childhood
education I don't think my dad would
have accomplished
half of what he accomplished if it were
not for my mom she was a remarkable
smart funny woman
who had to have the patience of Job to
be married to my dad
I used to play
um you know no limit poker when I was a
young man
I quit college once to go to uh New
Orleans and become a professional poker
player
I didn't last down there long either
but um
the game we had in the department I beat
these guys for like 30 years
he taught me to gamble very young taught
me how to gamble play poker play
Blackjack shoot traps bet on Sports when
Ed served in Korea he won enough money
to buy his parents their first home
he won all the time there so he stopped
playing poker the challenge was gone
plus he felt guilty taking money from
his comrades payday after payday he
broke his fast just once shortly before
discharged he played the Camp's
pharmacist with the stakes being the
seasickness pills he needed for the long
Voyage Home
he won
but yeah I'm a very good poker player
caught my son when he was about
four
he's a good poker player now he did give
us all a strong sense of the importance
of social justice and the importance of
taking care of those people in society
whose Society otherwise seemed to want
to overlook he loved poker but I think
in many ways he was a poker player and
just about everything that he did he
realized that that part of it is about
the cards that you're dealt and part of
it's about the things that you know but
the bigger part of the game really is
about the relationships that you have
with other people your ability to be
able to read what somebody else is going
to be able to give you and to take a
compromise when you can and some of the
times know that it's time to walk away
from the game Ed Sigler had an amazing
ability to work across sectors he and
several of his colleagues from various
disciplines established the field of
Child Development and social policy
he and I co-authored the first two
graduate textbooks that defined the
field
I'm extremely thankful on so many levels
for Ed Ziggler's impact of course he's
one of the most impactful psychologists
of the last 100 years
really making
an extraordinary transition from
mastering and contributing to basic
developmental science and then moving to
applied developmental science and
essentially creating the field of Child
Development and public policy a field of
intellectual disability owes its Origins
to Dr Ed Ziggler and the work of the
Special Olympics movement you know my
mom the founder of the Special Olympics
movement was always indebted to Ed
always throughout her life and called on
him frequently to ask for advice on the
design of programs the evaluation of
programs how to promote and explain to
policy makers the value of these kinds
of interventions before Head Start
there were programs where poor children
in this country
I think of Susan Gray's project down in
Nashville
the Deutsche project in New York City
there were exactly one in New Haven that
was sponsored by the Ford Foundation
but what characterized those programs
was they were interested only in
education
only in education
um and um
what Head Start did was it introduce
really the whole child approach the
whole child concept first was
articulated back in 1930 in a conference
on children that was being held by the
White House and it was a concept that
was kicked around and people talked
about and I think people understood the
importance of it it's ironic that it was
first mentioned in 1930 the very year
that Ed ziger was born but it wasn't
really until Head Start did anybody
actually took it serious enough to
actually do anything with that concept
it was an academic concept that Ed
turned into a reality in terms of how we
treat Children and Families
sadly there are little children who are
already headed for lives of frustration
and misery no one ever read them a story
taught them a nursery rhyme showed them
about colors letters and numbers
beginning in 1964 sir Shriver who was
the head of uh who are on poverty really
had this big committee that planned that
start
I was the youngest member
[Music]
remember the most was about the wisdom
that went into the planning of this
program and it all started with the
convening of a group called The Cook
committee and they had the wisdom to see
that you needed a healthy child to have
a child that would be prepared to learn
that you had to involve the parents to
really be supportive of that child's
development and learning and also that
the parents in turn would learn from
being part of such a comprehensive
program the planning committee was made
up of leading Scholars from diverse
disciplines
including free school education
Pediatrics
child development
Clinical Psychology
social work
and nursing
the planning committee's overarching
goal for Head Start
was the optimal development of the
children experiencing the Head Start
program
the planning committee unfortunately
provided a very long list of sub goals
to reach this major goal
and this long list resulted in the clear
goal of Head Start remaining ambiguous
I myself then in my own scholarship
decided to simplify by designating the
four systems that were absolutely most
critical in impacting human development
first and foremost
is the family system
the other three
being the health system
the education system
and the child care system
where so many children spend those
critical early years of life
we had this big Ballroom in with a new
Colonial Hotel it's a whole battered
hotel we didn't even have file cabinets
applications began pouring in
we used to keep the applications off
this Ballroom or restrooms and and in
them were bathtubs and we kept the
applications and those mascots
now what jewel Sugarman did that was
really brilliant was hired substitute
School teachers and they were sent there
and they would go through these
applications and if they had an
educational component a health component
if they had all the components of its
dark they would check it and there'd be
like five checks and if they'd give them
the five checks the check for Head Start
would go out to them started doing that
you know that you had to you had to put
in place a lot of poor programs
and realized very early on that there
needed to be a way to be able to bring
people into the profession of caring for
children and families and that's where
he came up with the idea of the CDA the
Child Development Associates credential
we are still having the conversation
about what it means to create a
professional field of practice for Early
Childhood Educators the competencies and
standards of early childhood education
and I can't tell you how many nacie
members and how many individuals who
I've come in contact with who will talk
about the very first thing that they did
was to get their CDA and what that did
in helping them understand how deeply
they cared about this profession how
they wanted to make a career out of it
and how it became the jumping off point
for these extraordinary women and men
who are now leaders system leaders
educator leaders in our field it's
really quite remarkable so Dr Ziegler's
Legacy lives on it's an honor and a
privilege to celebrate his life we
originally thought we would enroll 25
000 children in that first summer
program
applications for a head start began
pouring into oeo
and we wound up enrolling over 560
000 children
in that first summer
Head Start was also very popular at the
White House
Lady Bird Johnson was the honorary
chairperson of Head Start
and President Johnson
who was himself an ex-teacher was very
enamored with Head Start
the person who originally ran Head Start
was Julie Richmond Julie was a
pediatrician and my mentor
a brilliant brilliant man
at the age of 35 I was hired by
President Nixon
to run head starts and to run the
Children's Bureau I was Nixon's agent
for All Children's programs
in um in the United States which the
most important one and the largest being
Head Start
I wrote about Ed in my book preschool
education in America reviewed his books
and interviewed him for Publications
including a piece we wrote together on
his early days at Head Start
as he talked about when President
Richard M Nixon
vetoed the comprehensive Child
Development act in 1971. Ed's deep
knowledge of policy research all the
players came out
but he also knew the inside story he
knew the bureaucratic infighting and he
talked about it in a way that was candid
and witty
Ed would give you his opinions
rationales suggestions and a wealth of
evidence to back up his views in an open
way
as he said
his politics were children
his goal was always to extend child
welfare
upon taking charge of Head Start
I immediately announced
that Head Start would mount
an improvement
and Innovation effort
and that Head Start would become a
National Laboratory
in which we would Mount and assess
programs holding promise
for improving the development of
children living in poverty
in my book Head Start and Beyond which I
wrote some 20 years ago I spelled out
what a modeled program
where poor children would be
a three-year conception to age three
program for infants and toddlers like
Early Head Start
then you follow this with a high quality
two-year full day full year program
which provides four children the
preschool education they need
while providing Head Start parents high
quality child care they need so they can
work
in 1972 I was a research associate at
high scope in Ypsilanti Michigan
beginning work on my first Early
Childhood Program evaluation
it was a study of the new home start
demonstration project
I was not aware at the time that this
was to be important Through The Years in
my relationship with Ed
in the early 70s he and others in what
was in the office of child development
in the old department of health
education and Welfare we're developing
the first Head Start policy manual head
start's most serious problem has always
been inconsistent quality
some programs are excellent some are
mediocre and a few are poor
this situation began before the first
Center opened its doors
the project started off so big and so
fast
that quality controls were left behind
from 1965 to 1970 Head Start had
absolutely no performance standards
every Head Start Center was essentially
doing whatever it cared to do and
whatever they felt was Head Start
I thus with the very first performance
standards which lasted to the Clinton
Administration when they were updated
guaranteed that Head Start was a genuine
program in which every Head Start Center
did a certain set of activities
and I and my staff created The Head
Start policy councils
which must consist at least half of
parents
and these policy councils still exist
and are the ruling body of each Head
Start Center
giving parents this power has made
parents the most effective advocates for
Head Start
when President Carter tried to move Head
Start From health education and Welfare
to the new Department of Education
this would have destroyed Head Start as
we know it
and it was parents
winter seated
and kept at start
in Hew where it has had a comfortable
life
poker's assessing people when they're
bluffing when they're not bluffing that
happened in Washington all the time
somebody tried to throw a bluff at you
like that guy at OMP did
that was just a block one of the most
significant initiatives that Ed and I
worked on is the school of the 21st
century which forever changed the way
schools operate
schools begin to serve children the
death of the child through middle school
and Adolescence
they also provide various Support
Services in addition to academics
millions of schools around the country
are schools of the 21st century and the
program also spawns similar initiatives
Dr Ziegler conceptualized what is now
known as schools of the 21st century or
21c now in over 1300 communities
Nationwide in rural urban and Suburban
areas with year-round Services beginning
at Birth and focusing on the evolving
needs of the whole child through age 12
21c schools create an invaluable
platform to build on for success in
school and Beyond
sad fact is somewhere on the 35 percent
of all of our children arrive at school
not optimally ready to profit from the
school experience too many children are
simply not getting a good preschool
education poor quality of child care is
compromising their growth and
development so if we can just use the
school as the site where children could
get good preschool education and and
child care as well that would be a void
that's badly in need of billing the idea
of the school of the 21st century is why
should children go to school then have
to go to the doctor's office someplace
else or the dentist's office someplace
else we know where the children are
they're in the schools that's where we
should be putting all of the services
that are affecting the lives of Children
and Families right there where they are
in the schools the comer Ziggler
initiative
is really an effort to support the
development of children in a way that
they want to learn and be successful and
they want to manage themselves in a way
that is respectful helpful useful to
themselves and to others the way our
program became about is that we were
working in the same building but
separately and had never thought about
trying to work together
but we had the same Foundation executive
working with us and it occurred to him
that if we put the two programs together
we would be even stronger that program
was so successful that they were accused
of cheating on the state tests and they
had to take it over again they did
better the second time than they did the
first it wasn't cheating
it was Child Development it was support
for Child Development it was
reorganizing the system so that you
could
create
an experience for the children that
everybody developed and they could learn
it was very much in favor of having
graduated rates namely that he would
allow there to be Universal Pre-K but he
knew that there would be a waste of
money if we gave this Pre-K to very
affluent family first of all a lot of
affluent families wouldn't take it and
secondly that they could pay in a way
that disadvantaged families couldn't so
he was very very enthusiastic about the
idea of having a graduated scale and to
an economist this is like a payment
schedule based on needs and they so I
thought he he made some very useful
contributions to me and I Incorporated
that in some of my own work he made a
real difference in terms of social
policy in the United States
he was smart he was Savvy he was
connected he knew how to bridge Academia
and the real world he was one of a
handful of people that had it all when
it came to Early Childhood he understood
the policies he understood the mechanics
of early childhood and why and it was
failing in many ways many of our
families and in addition to that he
understood the politics of Washington in
1978 Ed had been back from Washington
D.C for about six years and had been
completely convinced that the biggest
challenge that we have in applied Child
Development is that people who
understand Child Development don't
understand much about policy and people
who understand and are making policy
decisions on behalf of Children and
Families don't know much about the
science of Child Development and so in
1978 he got a grant from the Archibald
Bush Foundation of Minnesota to create
the bush Center in child development
social policy at the bush Foundation we
invest in great ideas and the people who
power them
that is our tagline and it's also our
strategy
and marrying
Child Development research
with policy formation
translating the science into strategies
to support the well-being of kids and
families is a great idea
the Investments we made in the creation
of the Yale center from way back in 1977
are significant in the history of the
Bush foundation and in our future we're
excited to continue to see the long-term
impact of this work
the Smith Richardson foundation's long
relationship with Ed Zigler began in
1986 when he helped the foundation
launch its children and families at risk
program
at the time the foundation was concerned
about the well-being of children living
in unstable families with low incomes
and limited opportunities for Upward
Mobility
we asked several leading social policy
experts to identify Scholars who
understood best what kinds of public
policies and programmatic interventions
could most effectively promote the
healthy development of children from
disadvantaged backgrounds they all
pointed to Ed it was really Ed Ziegler's
Vision that created the bush Center in
child development and social policy at
Yale that we renamed the Edward Ziegler
Center in child development and social
policy in 2005. it was a way to be able
to remember his legacy but it was also a
way to be able to remind us all of the
fact that a good Vision a good
imagination can create things that can
have a huge impact on everyone else that
follows simply because you're impacting
the way in which they think about things
the Ziegler Center has changed the
trajectory of many people at Yale who
have participated in it taken people who
understood and were interested in
science and made them very fascinated
about how to move policy people who
understand stood policy but didn't know
much about child development and helped
them be able to gain the skills that
they needed in order to be able to be
the kind of people who would be the
leaders of the future
I think in all of the people that I have
met and combine these
incredible ways of being you know he
eminently was grounded in his very
humble beginnings and he was sort of
Scrappy to the very end because he
always had to fight for everything and
yet at the same time his being was
hallmarked by this consummate
intelligence you would tell him
something and he would remember it a
half a decade later or he would you come
up with profound ways of thinking afresh
about something so that I would say that
of all the people that I've known and I
probably most people who've come in
contact with him it was that combination
of drive and energy and inventiveness
and intelligence that really made him so
incredibly special so incredibly
valuable to Yale and to the entire
community that cares about children and
families in this country and in others
Ed knew from his research that
the baby's first teacher is their parent
and that they need to form a strong
relationship mothers and fathers need to
form a strong relationship with their
babies and their babies so need to be
able to form that relationship too and
that's why the very first days of a
baby's life are so deeply deeply
important and that's why he cared about
parental leave and parents being able to
take the time off from work to be able
to form that strong bond with their baby
he also realized in 1993 he wasn't going
to be able to get a paid parental leave
so he took a compromise and he worked
with Chris Dodd and other people in
Washington DC to create the Family
Medical Leave Act in 1993 which wasn't
paid but nonetheless protected
appearance ability to be able to take
time off and form that important bond
with their child it took me seven years
to pass family medical leave without pay
it was veto two or three times and
etiquest was terrific help on that it
could explain it in ways that people
would understand I was talking to Bill
Clinton several years ago on the
anniversary of the signing of the bill
it was the first piece of legislation he
signed in a law as president he said as
a former president people stopped me all
the time and say hello and this that and
the other he said the one issue they
bring up more than any other issue was
the fact that I was the president that
signed the the law of the Family Medical
Leave Act of all the things I was
involved in that's the one thing they
bring up more than anything else but
we're realizing now is that it's
critical that families have access to a
paid leave in order to make it possible
for them to actually take advantage of
the provisions under the family FMLA and
that research
from the 1970s that he and his students
did is still the research that people
are citing
and today we have over eight states that
now have a fully paid parental leave and
the federal government has it for
service workers we're knocking at the
door now on a vision that Ed had back in
1993. he supported us in finding the
yield China program on child development
at a Yale University
tacticular had a lifelong commitment to
providing the whole child approach to
education
as a high the start the yield China
program on Child Development aims to
provide children a good start through
cross-cultural academic collaborations
above everything else Ed cared most
deeply about teaching and mentoring and
making the next generation of leaders to
be able to carry on the work and carry
the work forward I had the honor of
being in Ed's orbit for 21 years first
as a graduate student and then as
assistant director of the Bush then
Ziegler Center
my role at the Ziegler Center was
running the Ziggler fellows program
which trained Yale Affiliates at
multiple levels undergrads grad students
post-docs early career and mid-career on
how to work at the intersection of Child
Development and social policy a field
that Ed essentially founded
I chose to attend graduate school at
Yale to be part of this fellowship
program so it was really incredible to
eventually lead it with Ed
we organized a weekly social policy
lunch lecture series which brought
renowned people in the field to Yale to
speak about their work this was both a
Yale course and a series open to the
entire Yale Community as well as to the
general public in New Haven it was one
of the first if not the first Yale
courses of this kind
the series drew a large diverse crowd
every week during the Academic Year for
decades
the Ziggler fellows program also
featured an annual trip to Washington DC
where fellows visited various players in
the social policy making process on
their home turf to learn about their
jobs we also had a small seminar that Ed
and I co-taught
over the course of just the 12 years I
worked at the Ziegler Center hundreds of
fellows participated in the fellowship
program
Ed as we all know had an incredibly long
list of accomplishments but he always
said that his proudest accomplishment
was the many students and fellows he
trained over the course of his long
career there are over 500 Ziegler Center
fellows out there in the world just from
this one site here alone and they're in
Academia and they're in government and
they're in philanthropy and they're at
non-profit institutes and they're
writing about child development and
social policy for newspapers they are
all over the place doing all kinds of
different elements of work necessary in
order for us to be able to not just talk
about how to help children and families
but actually do it in my current
position as Chief research officer at a
national child advocacy organization I
draw on what I learned from Ed on a
weekly basis and I'm sure that most of
Ed's former students and Ziggler fellows
do the same
the Ziggler fellow alumni list reads
like a who's who of the field of Child
Development and social policy Ed was
right to be proud and I'm honored to be
part of it and among those Ed brought
into the field
I knew from the beginning that I was
extremely fortunate to have Ed as my
mentor
but I truly appreciated him when I did a
summer internship at the office of Child
Development which he had led
the first thing I saw when I walked in
the door was this giant portrait of Ed
Ziegler
people there spoke of him with such
reverence and over the years I became
increasingly aware of the admiration and
appreciation people had Fred everywhere
but especially among child Advocates and
practitioners
Ed was a scholar and he advised his
students to be Scholars first if they
wanted to have an impact to earn not to
expect attention from policy makers
but at heart he was an advocate for
children especially children who were
overlooked and underserved
that heartfelt commitment to improving
children's lives is what people
experienced and revered him for
he was also a Savvy and extraordinarily
effective he was willing to collaborate
with people from every political side to
find common ground this is as we all
know a rare quality these days
she persisted and regrouped when
necessary reminding us all that we might
not be successful in a particular moment
but we need to be ready when the right
moment came along
Ed taught us to remain Vigilant after
victories because successes can be
easily reversed he had a vision that his
students and everybody who worked with
him
needed to be the very very best they
could be and that it was his job to
inspire that bestness in all of us if I
was working on a chapter or working on a
journal article with Ed I felt like the
weight of all the children of the world
was was on my shoulders with this
article that that the lives of babies
were in the balance on the basis of just
some article that I was writing and I
think it was really because he he
carried that kind of sense of urgency
too if you called him up you better be
prepared for the answer because he was
going to give it to you straight and I
appreciated that about him if I was off
on something he didn't hesitate to tell
me he would edit with this big red pen
that you would get it back and you would
think oh my gosh am I going to possibly
survive this my office was uh in many
ways a home to many of students after
their encounters with that so yes it is
true he was hard but it was always in
everybody's best interests and we all
strive to live up to his expectations
for all of us and frankly I think he
made every one of us better Scholars as
a result of that Ed turned me into a
scholar first and foremost whose
activism Drew from science
so what was it like being ed student
it could be terrifying at times he did
not tolerate fools or students who gave
up on themselves but he always had his
students backs he always picked us up
when we faltered and he always
celebrated our achievements he was like
a second father to me that is the kind
of person who will tell you what he
thinks to your face and defend you
behind your back if you didn't know
where you stood with Ed Ziggler you
simply were not paying attention he even
made it perfectly clear where things
stood but you also knew exactly why he
was that way because he took it so
seriously and as a result it was
impossible to not take it seriously with
him I remember Larry Aver telling me
before I even applied to Yale
that working with Ed would give me a
tough exact thing
irascible advisor
but one who would remain steadfast and
loyal to me for the rest of my career
and Larry was so right
Ed was with me at every step writing
letters of recommendation
being a cheerleader telling me I could
do it helping me to reflect on things
and pushing me to take the next step
in my second year of graduate school
family tragedy befell my extended family
and I thought I would need to grow up
out of graduate school to fulfill my
responsibilities to my extended family
Ed to ask Larry do you want to drop out
of graduate school and I said no
he said then let's find a way
and he promptly brainstormed with me
how to keep me in graduate school for me
remembering Ed now is more about the
ways in which he welcomed encouraged and
supported me and all of his other
graduate students into the world of what
I will call provocative scholarship
inextricably linked with impassioned
action
the admiration and respect that AP and
the psychology Community have for Ed are
beyond measure Dr Robert Sternberg
another former APA president awarded a
presidential citation to add in 2003.
that same year it was recognized with a
mentor award in developmental psychology
and he previously received the AP award
for distinguished contributions to
Therian research in community psychology
yet I understand that Ed was the most
proud of receiving apa's Premier award
for outstanding lifetime contributions
to psychology in 2008. I will never ever
forget my first meeting with Dr Ziegler
when we were talking to him about the
idea that grew into jumpstart the
Americorps program that trains college
students to work one-on-one with
preschoolers of course we thought he
hated the idea and was completely
unhappy and about to throw us out of his
office based on his demeanor and how he
was interacting with this while we were
talking and then at the end he said I
like it and I'll give you a thousand
dollars to help get this idea off the
ground it completely changed everything
for us he didn't just give us the
thousand dollars from the old Bush
Center for Child Development he also
gave us an office right around the
corner from his office which was the
first jumpstart office ever what started
in that office has now grown into truly
a national movement over 60 000 college
students have served as jumpstart Corps
members they've worked with over a
hundred and twenty thousand preschoolers
all across the United States and I'm not
sure that any of that would have
happened without Dr Ziegler giving us
that first thousand bucks and believing
in us and believing in young people
which is one of the many amazing things
about Dr Ziegler's entire career I was
very early in my career and participated
in a conference in Burlington Vermont in
which it was the keynote of course as
always and I had some very minor role
and
um at some point during the day there
was a press conference being held and Ed
was going to meet with the local
reporters and invited me to come and
participate and I said oh my God I no
way I'm too intimidated I'm afraid of
the press I'm afraid that I'll be
misquoted and he said he looked me in
the eye and he said let me tell you
something
um if you want to kind of play in this
Arena and want to have an influence you
have to put yourself out there and be
willing to speak to the Press
do your best at putting out there what
you want to say but remember never
forget that once you say something you
have no control over what people do with
it
so you give it your best shot you don't
expect to have any say about what
happens after that
um and if you can't handle that kind of
pressure then don't expect that you're
going to be able to make a difference in
that Arena I never remember Ed wanting
to be on the camera wanting to be
covered wanting to be quoted except if
he thought it would assist and help the
issue it embody for me how one can
utilize academic training to
continuously try to make the world a
better place for everyone
I look back on my career post Yale and
recognized that it was not by accident
that those 35 some odd years at the
Hartford foundation for public giving
were centered around the development of
policies and programs to support young
children and their families
moreover on a very personal level my
career as a father has been shaped by
his teachings questioning and
encouragement to deeply understand and
engage in this remarkable life event
thank you so very much Ed for helping to
steer me onto these incredibly important
Paths of learning of being and of doing
it's a real honor and pleasure to have
the opportunity to highlight Ed's impact
on my life well I was honored to bring
together 23 Scholars practitioners and
Advocates to craft an article to honor
Ed entitled Pathways to a more peaceful
and sustainable world
the article provides an overview of
selected ongoing International efforts
that have been inspired by Ed's Vision
to improve programs and policies for
Young Children and Families
the efforts presented are in close
alignment with strategies articulated by
Ed several years later we found out that
red was going to need surgery and Dr Kim
the anesthesiologist went over to Dr
Zucker and said I was a head start
graduate my mother said that the only
reason that I turned out as well off as
I did was because I had such a good
start to education from the Head Start
experience that I had after the surgery
was over it really wasn't the kind of
follow-up that sounded like a doctor
checking in on a patient it was more
like a man checking in on his previously
unknown benefactor somebody that he felt
had really helped change his life
[Music]
the numbers of people
the numbers of policies
and the numbers of visionary steps
that he architected
LED this nation
to a far better however still imperfect
but far better agenda for Children and
Families he was brilliant he was at The
Cutting Edge of everything and and a
Visionary in every way
so we all have a lot to appreciate and
be thankful for
50 years ago Sergeant Shriver one of the
architects of the war on poverty
hand-picked a brilliant young academic
from Yale University Edward Ziegler to
serve as a leading expert tasked with
designing the program that became Head
Start
President Johnson spoke of this project
as in I quote a new war front on poverty
he said and again quote we set out to
make certain that poverty's children
would not be forevermore poverty's
captives
Professor Ziegler soon became known as
the father of Head Start
and with good reason
and even today
it is difficult to overstate how
audacious how revolutionary Dr Ziegler's
Vision really is
Head Start brings together everything
everything that matters most to young
children education health emotional
well-being nutrition Social Services
instead of treating children as isolated
individuals Head Start Embraces whole
families involving parents and making
sure their kids are ready to learn
Head Start is without question the most
effective early childhood development
program that our country has ever
developed
his gifts to the United States
do not stop with Head Start
he helped give our country family a
medical leave assistance with child care
zero to three
and with Dr Jim Comer the Cozy
initiative the Yale child study center
but his greatest Legacy
is the Stars
too numerous to name who have been
trained at Yale
under his tutelage Ed left an indelible
mark on our community and our nation it
was my great privilege to not only have
had the opportunity to work closely with
him but to have called him my friend and
today it is my great honor to join all
of you in Remembering as invaluable
contributions not only to his chosen
profession but to all of our Lives May
his spirit and vision continue to be a
guide to us all when I'm asked what am I
most proud of as a senator an offered a
lot of legislation I come back to
children every single time other things
may have had a larger impact at the
moment and so forth but nothing I did
will have the lasting impact that the
cluster of issues around children and
their families did Ned ziglet was the
author of an awful lot of those ideas
and how to get them done he wanted us to
always do better he wanted our country
to do better he wanted Scholars to do
better by by our country he wanted those
of us who were in The Profession
teachers and school administrators he
wanted us to do better because he knew
we could and he knew there was a better
future for children if only we dedicated
ourselves more fully to it upon
receiving one of his numerous Awards Ed
reflected on the Head Start program he
conceptualized he said if I had never
done anything else in my life that would
have been a life worth living
but of course Head Start was just one
way Ed improved our world
he advised every U.S president from
Lyndon Johnson to Barack Obama on child
and family policy he was a prolific
scholar who published over 40 books and
800 papers and he was pivotal to the
Family and Medical Leave acts Passage
throughout his life Ed brought much
honor to yell
an equal measure of Hope to millions of
youths across America
as we pay tribute to our devoted
colleague
let us find solace in the fact that Ed
Ziggler's Legacy endures through the
many lives he enriched
[Music]